bien mes chers collègues je vous
propose que nous
commencions si vous voulez bien je sais
qu'il y a pas mal de réunions cet
après-midi donc nous allons commencer
sans plus tarder nous recevons
aujourd'hui monsieur Fabrice friss qui
est président directeur général de de
l'AFP qui est accompagné de Monsieur
Philippe chetwin qui est directeur de
l'information de l'agence messieur je
vous remercie dans une actualité chargé
d'avoir acceptter de vous rendre
disponible pour venir de devant notre
commission la FP on le sait est une des
trois grandes agences de presse mondial
vous couvreit toute l'actualité partout
dans le monde les circonstances
actuelles en Ukraine et au ProcheOrient
bien entendu l'exercice de cette mission
complexe parfois extrêmement
dangereuse pour les les journalistes les
reporters et tout le personnel de de la
FP qui
interviennent sur le
terrain dans le monde médiatique dans
lequel vous évoluez le conflit ne se
limite pas la à la fureur des armes mais
également parfois à celle des des mots
la la vérité est devenue en en elle-même
un champ de de conflit un champ de
bataille don vous n'êtes plus simplement
des spectateurs mais également des
acteurs à part entière pour reprendre
une une situ une citation de Kipling la
première victime d'une guerre c'est
toujours la vérité votre position est
néanmoins singulière car vous n'êtes pas
un organe de presse comme les autres
pour reprendre l'expression de
l'historien David Colomb vous êtes au
sommet de la chaîne alimentaire de
l'information mondiale et à ce titre
évidemment vous êtes particulièrement
observé c'est donc sur ce terrain du
traitement de l'information que l'AFP
comme au demeurant d'autres grands
médias et pas uniquement en France je
pense à la à la BIB ici se trouve depuis
quelques semaines pris dans une
polémique qui pose en réalité des
questions fondamentales sur la sur
l'information son utilisation et son
impact sur nos sociétés pour revenir au
cas d'espèce la FP n'a pas utilisé le
terme de terroriste pour qualifier les
attaques perpétrées par le Hamas en
Israël le 7 octobre dernier cette I a pu
choquer ceux pour
lesquels cette qualification ne fait
aucun doute vous avez monsieur le
Président précisé la position
déontologique de l'agence dans les
tribunes parues le 31 octobre dans le
Figaro et et ce dimanche dernier dans le
monde monsieur shetwin vous vous êtes
également exprimé dans les médias à Cees
sujets au-delà de de de l'utilisation du
du
terme terroriste la couverture des
événements a également fait débat et je
peux le dire au sein de l'agence même
puisqu'il y a eu un un papier paru dans
dans la lettre qui s'est fait écho d'un
d'un mail envoyé par un un responsable
important de de de lafp émettant des des
des critiques sur la façon dont dont les
événements en MoyenOrient était couvert
si la Commission a choisi en en pleine
période budgétaire de vous entendre
c'est donc bien par souci de clarté et
de
compréhension pour que vous puissiez à
travers votre intervention et les
questions des sénatrices et des
sénateurs
développer votre politique en la matière
répondre à l'émotion qui n'est pas
illégitime évidemment et aux questions
qu'elle soulève que ce traitement de
l'information a suscité je veux
cependant profiter de ce propos
liminaire et je pourir le faire au nom
de l'ensemble de de mes collègues pour
apporter notre soutien à l'ensemble des
des agents de lafp qui interviennent sur
le terrain dans des conditions qui sont
évidemment extrêmement parfois
compliquées et aussi au péril de leur
vie sans plus tarder je vous propose de
de de prendre la parole pour un propos
liminaire et ensuite bien sûr chacun des
sénateurs et chacune des sénatrices qui
le souhaite pourront vous interroger
monsieur le présidentci merci monsieur
le Président le Sénat est un lieu où le
débat peut-être nuancé et où l'écoute
est réelle nous nous réjouissons donc
particulièrement de cette invitation
lafp prend très au sérieux les
accusations de biais dont elle fait
l'objet
d'abord parce que son statut voté en
1957 à l'unanimité du Parlement après un
long combat pour l'indépendance de
l'agence dispose c'est son article 2
qu'elle ne peut en aucune circonstance
tenir compte d'influence ou de
considération de nature à compromettre
l'exactitude ou l'objectivité de
l'information ensuite on le prend très
au sérieux parce que ce n'est pas de
n'importe quel biais qu'il s'agit la
plupart des critiques en France évoquent
un biais proalestinien mais certains
n'ont pas hésité à faire de l'agence un
vecteur de la monté de
l'antisémitisme c'est d'autant plus
grave et infamant que l'AFP est né en
août 1944 à la
Libération grâce à l'action d'une
poignée de résistant bientôt rejoint par
des rescapés de la Choa pour mettre fin
à la propagande et la censure imposée
par l'occupant nazi à l'office français
d'in formtion alors en place ces
accusations sont folles
elles ne sont pas que des propos de
plateau de télévision puisqu'un élu de
la République un député les a reprises à
son
compte les accusations sont parfois
outrancières mais vous avez raison
monsieur le Président le débat sur la
couverture du conflit lui est tout ce
qu'il y a de plus légitime et
attendu toutes les grandes rédactions
aujourd'hui sont secoué par des
discussions internes
parfois vive et lafp n'y échappe
paswin à mes côtés qui est directeur de
l'information de l'agence est en
relation étroite avec ses paèes des
grands médias
internationaux et tous disent que c'est
la couverture la plus complexe et
sensible qu'ils ont eu à organiser
depuis qu'ils sont en
poste ce n'est pas surprenant prenez le
sujet géopolitique le plus complexe et
chargé de passion qui soit A l'effet de
sidération de l'attaque du 7
octobre mélanger avec ces symptômes bien
connus de nos société contemporaines que
sont la polarisation des esprits
l'hystérisation du débat la prévalence
de la société du Commentaire offrez lors
bien sûr la caisse de résonance des
réseaux sociaux et des émissions où ça
clash et vous obtenez un cocktail des
plus
explosifs la polémique qui nous touch né
d'un article de presse qui se
scandalisait de ce que l'agence ne
qualifie pas le Hamas de groupe
terroriste en n'appelant pas un chat un
chat l'agence révélait ses noirs
penchants habilement l'article laissait
entendre qu'une nouvelle consigne venait
d'être donné en interne de proscrire
l'usage du mot s'agissant du Hamas comme
s'il s'agissait donc d'une consigne sur
mesure ce que l'article ne disait pas
c'est que cette consigne avait plus de
20 ans qu'elle s'appliquait à tous les
mouvements sans exception Boko Haram
état islamique Al-Qaïda j'en passe et
que d'ailleurs au passage la FP n'était
pas seule à appliquer cette règle
puisque les deux grands grands les deux
autres grands acteurs qui font le même
métier qu la sociciété de presse et
rters suivent exactement les mêmes
règles alors il est facile de moquer la
réflexion éditoriale sérieuse qui a
présidé à l'élaboration de cette règle
en l'assim au discussions byzantines sur
le sexe des anges c'est tout simplement
refuser de chercher à comprendre ce
qu'est le métier d'une
agence on aurait pu s'interroger sur un
biais si la règle avait été changée pour
ce cas
précis pas dans le cas contraire et
j'ajoute à l'intention de tous ceux qui
continuent de manifester leur
incompréhension supposons je dis bien
supposons parce que ça ne nous a jamais
effleoré l'esprit que nous renoncions à
cette consigne
éditoriale sous la pression des
commentateurs ou d'un certains camp
politiqu que dirait-on alors là oui on
serait fondé à parler d'une agence sous
influence depuis cette polémique pas un
jour ne passe sans qu'il faille répondre
à une nouvelle
interpellation
parfois la critique est fondée et
l'agence n'a absolument aucun problème à
connaître des choix éditoriaux
discutables elle l'a fait publiquement
oui elle aurait dû rendre compte le jour
même d'une projection organisée par les
autorités israéliennes sur les atrocités
du 7 octobre elle l'a fait en anglais
pas en français cela a un nom ça
s'appelle un raté qui n'en fait
pas parfois les attaques font sourire
samedi matin je reçois d'un ami un sms
me poussant un tweet et me disant juste
bon courage ce tweet d'un exjournaliste
dont je terrai le nom par charité disait
vous vous demandez pourquoi lafp refuse
d'employer le mot terroriste au sujet du
Hamas voici peut-être un élément de
réponse Phil chwin directeur de
l'information à la FP était ou est
encore membre du collectif photographers
for Palestine dont le but est de
raconter l'histoire de la Palestine
telle que vécu aujourd'hui filwin écrit
dans des revues comme electronic
Intifada et prêche dans des mosquées
écossaises il a fallu une journée pour
convaincre ce journaliste que Phil Chen
avait un homonyme entetemps le tweet
avait gagné plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de
suiveurs mais il arrive que les coups de
sonde pour voir soi
grave ils peuvent menacer alors
physiquement des
personnes vendredi dernier tous les
grands médias internationaux New York
Times CNN RS associété de presse et FP
ont dû se défendre de l'accusation que
certains de leurs photographes de Gaza
étaient en réalité au courant de
l'attaque et l'avait documenté non pas
comme journaliste donc mais comme
complice notre rédaction en chef a passé
la matinée à contrôler toutes les photos
prises par nos journalistes le 7 à
regarder l'heure et le lieu d'où elles
avaient été prises autant de temps pris
sur la couverture naturellement nous
avons dû expliquer que nos trois
photographes installés à gaz
qui travaillent de façon permanente pour
lafp parfois depuis plus de 20 ans qui
sont reconnus par des prises
internationaux se sont mobilisés dès que
l'attaque du Hamas a été connue ils ont
été réveillés par des tirs d'artillerie
et de roquettes se sont rendu alors à
proximité de la barrière entre Gaza et
Israël chacun était identifié clairement
comme journaliste sur son casque et son
gilet par balle les premières photos à
proximité de la barrière de Gaza ont été
réalisés plus d'une heure après le début
de l'attaque bref ils n'ont fait que
leur métier suivre l'événement à mesure
qu'il se déroulaiit sur le terrain tous
les autres médias attaqués ont pu
montrer comme nous qu'il n'étaiit en
rien coupable de ce qu'on leur
reprochait mais il a fallu 3 jours à
l'organisation qui avait lancé l'affaire
pour reconnaître que celle-ci était
close d'une phase phrase lapidaire en
prétendant qu'elle n'avait fait que
poser des questions et qu'elle avait été
mal comprise entre-etemps le mal était
fait les noms de ces photographes
avaient été jetés en pâture l'espace
d'une journée ils ont été considéré
comme terroriste et alors que nous
cherchons tous les moyens de les évacuer
vous imaginez que cela ne va pas nous
aider dans nos démarches pour qu'ils
intègrent la liste des quelques
chanceux c'est l'occasion pour moi de
dire que si jamais il arrivait un
malheur à l'un quelconque de nos neuf
salariés à Gaza cela susciterait au sein
de l'agence la même émotion que celle
que nous avons connu à l'occasion de la
mort du français Arman soldin en mai
dernier
ou de la grave blessure de notre jeune
photographe libanaise Christina assi
touchée par un tir au Sud Liban il y a
quelques
semaines parce qu'il participe autant
que n'importe quel autre salarié à
l'exercice de la mission d'intérêt
général de l'Agence et même probablement
davantage au vu de la difficulté de
témoigner de ce qui se passe à Gaza
sachez pour finir que cette polémique
sur le BIA proalestinien prêté à lafp
est purement française qu'on ne la
retrouve nulle part ailleurs elle sidère
nos équipes dans la région habituéses à
entendre plutôt que notre agence fait le
jeu
d'Israël nous avons reçu beaucoup de
messages privés d'encouragement
notamment nos clients mais je note qu'il
y a eu très peu d'expression publique de
soutien au travail de laafp probablement
pour ne pas être mêlé à une querelle
incandescente
comme il paraît qu'on n jamais mieux
servi que par
soi-même vous me permettrez peut-être
que je dise tout simplement qui d'autre
qui d'autre que l'AFP emploie 50
journalistes textes photos vidéos à
Jérusalem Gaza et ramala qui d'autre
parvenait encore jusqu'à samedi à
envoyer seul des images de
gazaville qui d'autre a diffusé depuis
le 7 octobre 242 reportages je ne parle
pas de simple factuel mais de vraies
histoires construites don 96 depuis
Israël 53 depuis Gaza et les territoires
occupés qui d'autre pour ne prendre que
quelques reportages de ce matin a
raconter l'histoire de ces jeunes d'un
kibou ravager qui retournent à l'école
après les enterrements ou interview le
créateur de la série Foda expliquant
pourquoi la guerre à Gaza avait dépassé
tous les scénarios
Maurice Levy a écrit une très belle
tribune intitulé jamais depuis la Choa
la communauté juive de France ne s'était
senti aussi isolé évoquant les 40
Français juifs assassiné le 7 il écrit
qui étai ces 40 français quelle était
leur vie étai-ils parents on ne sait
rien d'eux parce que l'on ne veut rien
savoir ni leur nom ni leurs âges ni leur
vie ni leur visage lafp a commencé de
raconter la vie de certaines de ses
victimes
grâce à son réseau de journalistes en
contact régulier avec des familles
d'otage et de la presse israélienne
elle est parvenue hier à identifier 208
des 239 otages recensés par les
autorités
elle a décompté au moins 34 enfants dont
17 de moins de 10 ans l'otage le plus
jeune est un nourrisson âgé de 9 mois
enlevé dans le kibut nirose avec son
frère Ariel 4 ans et ses parents de
jeunes trentenair h octogénaires
figurent parmi les
captifs qui d'autre que l'AFP a fait ce
travail
merci merci monsieur le Président sans
plus tarder on va commencer les
questions avec celle de notre rapporteur
sur la presse Michel logi merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président de la
FP je crois qu'il est quand même
important de de rappeler comme l'a fait
le président de la fond que l'Agence
France Presse fait partie des trois plus
grandes agences au monde vous êtes aussi
l'image de la France à l'étranger
puisque vous êtes une des agences les
plus représentées alors au moment où
vous êtes mis en difficulté faut dire
les choses quand même avec ces
polémiques ces critique euh déjà je
voudrais savoir est-ce que vous êtes
rendu sur place à titre personnel pour
voir un petit peu la situation comment
les choses s'organisaient puisque euh il
y a des caricatures aussi puisque
l'agence francepess AFP est devenue
agence France-Palestine en tous les cas
ce sont des propos que j'ai lu euh sur
certaines sur certains articles euh vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure des des moyens
en terminant votre introduction moi je
voudais que vous nous précisiez un petit
peu quels sont les moyens permanents qui
existent sur ce secteur du monde et
quels sont les moyens supplémentaires
que vous avez pu mettre en place alors
moyens humains et moyens financiers
aussi parce que il y a pas que les
moyens aussi les moyens financiers
est-ce que vous avez mis des moyens
supplémentaires depuis le début de ce
conflit je rappelle et vous l'avez dit
mais rapidement mais je rappelle quand
même que non seulement il y a des
dépêches bien sûr pour la presse écrite
il y a aussi les photos et il y a aussi
les reportages vidéos puisqueaujourd'hui
une grande partie de votre activité ce
sont aussi les reportages vidéo euh si
vous n'êtes pas allé sur place mais
peut-être que votre directeur
l'information pour pourit nous indiquer
quelles sont les conditions de travail
actuellement des journalistes sur le sur
le terrain et puis pour regarder un
petit peu l'importance et tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment dans cette partie du
monde combien avez-vous de de médias
abonnés qui reprennent l'ensemblefin qui
bénéficie de votre travail tout
simplement qui bénéficie de votre
travail je vous laisser répondre à ces
premières
questions je précise
que je ne suis pas journaliste comme
vous le savez je n'ai pas vocation à
intervenir dans le débat
rédactionnel si je le fais sur ces
question c'est naturellement parce que
l'agence en tant qu'entreprise est
attaquéeil chewin est journaliste il va
prendre ce type de question
mercibuse pour non je suis pas allé sur
place depuis les attentats parce que il
y a tellement de boulot à faire sur
place par les équipes que d'avoir le
directeur de l'information là-bas ça en
fait ça ça devient ça va empêcher le
travail jour à jour j'ai visité Israël
plusieurs fois en tant que rédactur chef
de
l'agence et aussi en tant que directeur
de l'information on était toujours très
bien accueilli par par les autorités
israéliennes dans une manière très posi
postif la priorité pour nous après à le
le 7 octobre c'était de mettre le
maximum de moyens sur le terrain de de
faire le boulot qui dans le contexte
actuel et quelque chose qui est fait 24
24 he sur 24 he ça va dire oui on a
mettre une quinzaine d'envoyers spéciaux
texte photos vidéo en permanence sur le
terrain en Israël eu et c'est avec ces
moyens on a renforcé le bureau de
Jérusalem mais aussi on on a des équipes
qui qui va partout en Israël dans le sud
pour faire des des reportages dans dans
avec l'armée dans tous les kbuts qui
étit affecté par les les événements
atroces de 7 octobre dans le Nord sur
sur la frontière avec le Liban partout
l'idée l'idée c'était vraiment de de de
couvir toute la société israélienne à ce
moment clé normalement dans quand j'ai
dis normalement encore une fois j'ai
géré plusieurs conflits Israël ou
palestinien notamment des des événements
à Gaza dans le passé c'était toujours
possible de mettre des des renforts à
Gaza pour pour des autres conflits
guerres et cetera cette fois-ci c'est
pas possible normalement on est on a
neuf staff en total à Gaza il inclus se
journalistes et bien sûr c'est c'est
important d'avoir des autres à côté
d'eux des gens qui viennent ou de
Jérusalem ou d'illeurs pour pour les
aider pour les renforcer pour les guider
euh dans des moments très difficiles et
de montrer aussi que l'agence avec eux à
ce M qui qui est difficile
euh si on a réussi jusqu'ici eu de de de
faire notre boulot là-bas c'est c'est
vraiment cette mélange de journalistes
israélien qu'on a sur le terrain
palestinien et étranger c'est vraiment
une équipe très très mixte
euh en en terme de condition de travail
à ça dépend il y a bien sûr en Israël
euh le c'est la sécurité qui prime ça
veut dire que parfois c'est la question
d'accès ça se
négocie parfois on a besoin de
travailler avec les autorités pour avoir
accès et cetera mais mais bien sûr on
est allé partout dans toutes les
diffantes qui boutent qui étaient
affecté toutes les les les les villes
qui étaient
affectées et on a une présence vraiment
dans tout le sud là toutes les image qui
donne sur Gaza de cidro par exemple dans
le sud même chose dans le Nord ça ça se
négocie ça dépend il y a bien sûr une
situation de sécurité qui est qui est
considérable ça veut dire queon peut pas
juste aller n'importe où mais ça ça
c'est un peu notre boulot de d'aller
dans dans le maximum différentes
endroits deeline et cetera euh à Gaza
c'est autre chose eu c'est extrêmement
difficile nos journalistes travaillent
dans des situations très très bah ils
sont dans une précarité extrême on a
évacué notre bureau à Gaza City parce
que c'est c'était dans la zone où les
les Israéliens nous a demandé tout le
monde de de de fuir on a évacué notre
bureau il y a des jours de semaines euh
je pense c'est bien connu que notre
bureau a souffert un frappe euh il y a
une semaine il y avait personne dedans
mais les les dommages son le bâtiment
sont sont considérables euh nos
journalistes avec le famille euh en
total c'est 70%
euh sont dans des appartements destente
des des des des des situations très très
très difficiles dans dans le sud Gazin
euh ils font un boulot remarquable dans
les circonstances euh mais ils sont dans
une situation très très très précaire
notamment parce qu'il y avit des des des
des frappes qui continuent autour d'eux
certains ont perdu des des membres de la
famille euh presque à la moitié ont
perdu le le résidence Le le
l'appartement ou ouou leur maison euh
mais il continue de de de bosser faire
un travail remarquable avec le bureau de
Jérusalem il travaille main à main jour
à jour avec le bureau de Jérusalem toute
la copie passe via le bureau de jérus il
travaille très bien euh ensemble
euh en terme de quantité de clients
c'est je pense on utilise un chiffre
comme 4 5000 autour du monde euh il
inclu des grosses agences qui
redistribuent notre copie ou nos images
à d'autres médias dans dans le P ah il y
a presque pas une grande médiia du monde
qui qui qui prend pas effet et pour ma
part je suis allé au Liban la semaine du
20 octobre euh je vous l'ai dit je ne
suis pas journaliste donc aller en
Israël m'occuper de la couverture c'est
pas mon sujet en revanche m'occuper de
la sécurité de nos salariés Salai nous
avons eu deux journalistes blessés le
même jour où un reporteur de rter était
mort et je suis aller là-bas logiquement
pour euh rencontrer les parents aller à
l'hôpital voir qu'elle est qu ques
étaient les conditions de suivi et au
passage puisque nous parlons de biais
propalestinien faire un questionréponse
au bureau de Beyrouth nous avons une
trentaine de journalistes et j'ai passé
un très seul quart d'heure sur le thème
d'une agence qui était
proisraélienne pour une raison très
simple en
l'occurrence un des deux journalistes
qui a été blessé qui lui a été n'a pas
perdu connaissance et convaincu que le
tir venait
d'Israël il était fou furieux que dans
notre dépêche nous n'ayons pas attribué
la responsabilité parce que nos règles
éditoriales ne le permettent pas ça a
donné lieu à tout un déversement
d'émotion assez exactement symétrique de
celui qui se passe à
Paris voilà c'est la réalité qu'on
vit maintenant toutes vos questions ce
sera plus simple en commençant par le
président
retaillou merci je voudrais d'abord
remercier le président la fond
d'organiser cette audition je pense
qu'elle est importante bien sûr il y a
eu la polémique mais l'Agence France
Presse alimente de très très nombreux
organes de presse écrites ou audiovisuel
en France donc c'est vous avez un rôle
qui est un rôle fondamental et j'oublie
pas que à quelques semaines du du PLF il
y a il y a aussi une contribution des
Français au fonctionnement de la FP et
donc il y a une responsabilité
particulière du contrôle du du Parlement
euh vous avez eu raison et en tête de
mon propos je voudrais redire que les
reporteurs notamment de guerre pai un
lourd tribut et il faut y penser et on
ne peut pas faire cette ition sans
commencer par
cela pour le reste bien sûr que vous
faites un travail difficile monsieur le
Président d'abord parce que c'est la
guerre ensuite parce que désormais les
guerres utilisent pas seulement les
armes mais leur arme est aussi l'arme de
la
désinformation et cette guerre là est
aussi hybride bien que elle se déploie
aussi avec des moyens classiques et et
puis il y a aussi l'aire de la
postvérité des réseaux sociaux de ces
informations qui ne sont pas contrôlées
qui brouillent la perception que nous
pouvons avoir de la réalité mais
justement ça oblige aussi votre
entreprise à une très très grande
rigueur ce que nous avons compris
notamment à travers les premières
questions qui ont été posées par notre
rapporteur Michel
lougier c'est que pour remplir vos
missions vous avez un réseau très
puissant de correspondants on n a pas
parlé peut-être en parlerons nous vous
avez aussi une charte de bonne pratique
déontologique qui doit vous permettre de
traiter l'information de la façon la
plus distanciée la plus objective la
plus impartiale possible ça c'est
fondamental j'ai trois questions très
rapides à vous poser vous pourrez y
répondre je suis désolé parce qu'en même
temps on a une séance sur le pfss donc
le temps est compté la première chose
c'est comment faites-vous pour
recueillir les informations d'ordre
quantitatif sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à Gaza alors que le
principal émetteur est le ramas et qu'on
sait par ailleurs que il manipule
aisément les chiffres comment vous vous
pouvez relayer des informations
quantitatives et où prenez-vous vos
sources deuxième élément vous l'avez
rapidement évoqué mais je reviens parce
que ça a été un certain nombre de
journaux américains grand journaux
américain grand journaux aussi du soir
français ils sont
revenus sur la frappe sur l'hôpital qui
avait été tropativement imputé et donc
par erreur on le sait désormaet à Israël
j'aimerais connaître quelles ont été les
mesures de prudence de précaution de
recoupement que vous avez eu avec
l'information pour que vous puissiez
vous assurer que dans votre dépêche les
les utilisateurs de ces dépêche ne
soient pas trompés sur ce point qui a
été un point quasiment qu' d'école en
réalité puisque des grands journaux
encore une fois pas seulement français
se sont fait berner et le trisème point
qui concerne directement la polémique
puisque vous l'avez redit vous avez fait
les deux d'ailleurs tribunes vous avez
eu l'occasion de vous expliquer dans
dans deux journaux du matin puis un du
soir qui sont tous les deux trèslus euh
vous dites que vous n'aimez pas vous
n'utilisez pas le mot terroriste c'est
une ligne éditoriale générale et pour
autant
euh nous avons retrouvé des dépêches où
ce mot est utilisé et vous le savez et
vous attendiez cette question je la
pose euh 20 février 2020 une menace
terroriste extrême droite en Allemagne 7
janvier 2015 juste e
après Charlie Hebdo où vous qualifiez
évidemment d'attentat terroriste
l'attentat de Charlie Hebdo et pour
autant vous ne voulez pas qualifier le
Hamas de terroriste alors que la France
l'Union européenne le qualifie
terroriste et et j'ai lu bien sûr les
tribunes dans lesquelles vous êtes
justifié mais mais vous comprenez que
c'est difficile à comprendre que tantôt
vous acceptez d'utiliser le terme de
terroristme et que pour d'autres cas ce
cas-là qui paraît tellement évident vous
le refusiez j'ai lu encore une fois vos
contre arguments mais j'aimerais vous
entendre à
nouveau Lord
Arcos c'est à peu près les mêmes les
mêmes questions bien évidemment euh moi
je suis très embêtée parce que bien
évidemment monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur on a nous
tous ce que vous ce que vous faites
écrire ce que vous publiez vous parliez
de désinformation parce que justement il
y a de tout et beaucoup de haine sur sur
Twitter et sur les réseaux sociaux euh
on compte sur vos dépêches pour pouvoir
dire des choses vraies comme le
président retaillou moi j'ai relever
aussi et c'est pour ça que je voulais
que vous reveniez dessus le fait que par
exemple quand vous associez à ftin post
sur certaines photos vous parlez bien
d'Al-Qaïda comme organisation terroriste
euh et donc je ne comprends toujours pas
pourquoi est-ce que pour alqaïda euh
vous le mentionnez quand même euh alors
bien sûr en association avec d'autres
journaux mais ce sont vos photos euh et
pas pour le Hamas
voilà
adelziane merci président effectivement
merci à à vous monsieur fris et Monsieur
Chatwin d'être venu présenter
aujourd'hui pour nous donner des
explications des des éléments de
compréhension je dirais sur la
difficulté qu'il y a à mener ce travail
de vérité le président Lafond l'a évoqué
cette citation de Kling on la retrouve
ensuite au 20e siècle la première
victime de la guerre c'est bien souvent
la vérité euh moi mes questions elles
seront très rapides la première chose
c'est de bien comprendre et nous
expliquer nous donner des éléments de
compréhension sur lorsque vous parlez
comme les autres grandes agences AP et
Reuters cette règle éditorial qui veut
que dans la construction d'une
compréhension de faits sur le terrain
vous arriviez à objectiver au maximum
ces éléments parce que vous n'êtes pas
un journal d'opinion ou un un organe
d'opinion vous êtes un organe de presse
indépendant financé en partie par le par
l'État mais votre travail au même titre
que Reuters ou AP c'est d'être en
capacité de récupérer ces éléments
factuels et moi ce que je voudrais
comprendre et je pense que ça fait
partie des questions qui ont été posées
par le président retaillot par madame la
sénatrice D'cos comment cette règle
éditoriale cette règle qui vous permet
de rédiger vos dépêche AFP va être
ensuite reprise ce travail en fait que
vous faites en interne pour construire
cette pour construire cette
cette proposition éditoriale ma deuxème
question elle posait sur vos sources
d'information effectivement aujourd'hui
sur le théâtre des opérations dans les
zones de combat effectivement on l'a
redit la fermeture des canaux
d'information de cette capacité à avoir
des des informateurs des journalistes
sur place les journalistes ont payé un
lourd tribut depuis le début du
conflit plus d'une trentaine de
journalistes qui sont morts sur le
théâtre des opérations aujourd'hui on
l'a évoqué ces questions de sécurité
comment est-ce que vous êtes en capacité
de sécuriser vos vos journalistes vos
agents sur place à ma connaissance donc
il y a des journalistes à notre
connaissance à Gaza comment
travaillet-il et comment sont-ils en
capacité de récupérer de d'obtenir des
éléments d'information pour produire
cette information moi très clairement de
mon point de vue j'ai l'occasion de
travailler dans le passé avec lafp je
comprends aussi les mécanismes qui sont
à l'œuvre dans la manière dont vous
construisez cette cette cette
information la difficulté évidemment
c'est que dans le moment d'émotion que
nous avons vu moment de de nous avons
vécu ce moment de sidération le 7
octobre puis avec la douleur qui s'en
est suivie les moments de solidarité
d'émotions que nous avons témoigné à
l'égard des victimes des deux côtés vous
ce travaill là il est difficile en tant
que journaliste d'autant plus difficile
que vous êtes cette agence fierté de la
France aussi en terme d'information en
terme de capacité à porter une voix
spécifique sur des faits sur des
problématiques et sur des conflits donc
voilà quelles étaient mes deux questions
à votre attention je vous remercie
Pierre
as merci merci monsieur le Président je
je voudrais vraiment vous remercier très
sincèrement pour la qualité de de votre
propos et moi j'aimerais m'associer avec
les collègues euh au remerciement que
nous formulons pour toutes les personnes
qui sont sur sur le terrain
euh je ne sais pas comment elles font
pour vivre ça euh moi j'avoue que je
suis dans l'incapacité de regarder le
journal télévisé euh tellement les
images sont bouleversantes euh
abominables des deux côtés euh je je je
j'ai du mal à me mettre à leur place et
et à vivre psychologiquement ce qu'
pourrait vivre je je pense qu'il faut
croire vraiment dans dans leur métier
dans l'utilité du du journalisme et
aussi dans la force de ce qui nous
transmettent parce que
fait l'expérience de regarder une chaîne
Catarie et vous comprendrez quelle est
la force incroyable de ces
images quand on fait un choix de de
présenter certaines images et pas
d'autres on peut on peut dresser des
populations entières contre les uns et
contre les autres donc vous avez une
responsabilité qui est monstrueuse et
que je n'aimerais pas
assumer je fais un pas de côté euh en en
vous parlant d'un autre d'un autre
conflit qui est malheureusement
complètement sorti de l'actualité c'est
celui de l'artsar du
okaraba j'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention vos vos dépêches vous
nutilisez jamais le mot harzar si ce
n'est quand il est prononcé par les
Arméniens eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire que
vous vous estimer mais comme la plupart
des pays et la France la première je
vous en fais pas le reproche que le le
référendum de
1985 par lequel le peuple arartsariote a
défini son son indépendance
est nul et non avenu et donc vous
présentez l'artzar comme une république
autoproclamée ce qui est rigoureusement
le langage de l'Azerbaidjan mais encore
une fois je vous en fais pas le le
reproche ce que j'aimerais comprendre
c'est dans le choix des mots que vous
faites parce que là le mot est essentiel
quand vous dites okarabat quand vous
dites SAR vous prenez parti pour l'un ou
l'autre camp et j'aimerais savoir quel
est le processus intellectuel et le
processus collégial aussi parce que je
je suppose que c'est une décision
collégiale qui fait que vous choisissez
un un mot plutôt plutôt qu'un autre et
comment ensuite vous le justifier à
l'extérieur parce que par exemple c'est
quelque chose que que je n'ai pas trouvé
sur sur votre site pourquoi vous
n'utilisez pas le le le le le mot
AR donc c'est c'est ça que j'aimerais
comprendre parce que peut-être que ça
permettrait aussi un éclairage sur la
façon dont vous voulez ou pas utiliser
le mot terroriste qui qui lui aussi
renvoie une nomenclature internationale
à des règles de droit donc c'est ça qui
m'intéresserait je vous remercie Bernard
fieller merci monsieur le Président donc
moi aussi j'ajoute un petit peu tout le
respect qu'on a pour pour les gens qui
qui risquent leur vie pour pouvoir nous
nous informer moi c'est une question
simple en dans prolongement de celle qui
ont été posé vous nous dites que votre
ligne élictoriale vous vous interdit
d'utiliser
le mot terroriste qui est un mot
pourtant qui existe dans la langue
française jeir vous avez d'autres
exemples de mots qui sont comme ça que
vous qui sont affichés comme n'étant pas
possible d'être utilisé par vos ligne
électorale
merci moi aussi je vais ajouter quelques
questions dans un souci de de
compréhension et peut-être de réponse à
des à des polémiques bon on a beaucoup
parlé du du mot terroriste on a compris
à travers vos tribunes que derrière
l'utilisation du mot terroriste la la la
la la crainte que vous avez c'est de
prendre parti dans une situation qui est
est parfois complexe à analyser dans
dans l'instant mais une fois que cela a
été jugé est-ce que vous avez les les
mêmes réserves pour utiliser le beau
terroriste je pense en particulier au
aux
auteurs des attentats du du Bataclan il
y a eu un procès la justice française
c'est s'est prononcée et bien pour des
actes de terrorisme est-ce que dans ces
cas-là votre règle
rédactionnelle vous permet de de
d'utiliser le mot
terroriste dans le prolongement de la la
la question de de Bernard fialer sur
d'autres mots sur lequel vous avez des
des réserves la presse s fait écho de de
consiges interne euh demandant de ne pas
utiliser le terme Islam du Hamas mais
combattant du Hamas est-ce que vous
pourriez nous préciser si c'est bien une
consigne à ce moment nous donner aussi
des éléments de
d'explication de même sur les élément
d'explication on a bien noté ce que vous
nous avez dit monsieur le Président sur
euh sur le le raté comme vous l'avez dit
concernant le
euh la la la non communication des
images transmise par tal en tout cas pas
dans de manière rapide euh est-ce que il
y a eu aussi des questions sur le
traitement ou le temps relativement long
pour
traiter ce qui s'est passé lors de la
rêve parti est-ce que vous pourriez nous
donner des des explications de même sur
l'invasion de l'aéroport au dagastan qui
a donné lieu à un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur une autre ordre de
questions euh vous n avez dit que vous
avez une cinquantaine de de journalistes
permanents sur sur place h à Gaza euh je
crois que les journalistes à Gaza sont
tous Palestiniens est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire un peu quelles sont
les règles que vous
appliquez pour envoyer des locaux ou des
des gens d'autres pays en fonction des
des des zones et des tensions
existantes et puis peut-être une
une une question qui va nous éloigner un
petit peu mais vous avez dit qu'il y
avait les mêmes règles entre les trois
grandes agences internationale deux sont
américaines une est française est-ce que
finalement dans cette uniformisation des
règles et d'usage des mots est-ce que il
y a pas un peu une perte de la
spécificité d'être une agence
française je crois que l'essentiel des
questions est pour oui ok
oui je vais revenir sur la question des
des des chiffres utilisés par tous les
gros médias
euh de
Gaza c'est les chiffres qui vientent de
l'autorité hospitalier à Gaza bien sûr
sous le contrôle de Hamas sous
l'administration de Hamas
euh il faut distinguer distinguer là que
Hamas il y a la partie militaire il y a
parti politique et puis il y a
l'administration les les chiffres qui
viennent d' partie de l'administration
notamment autour de de qui vientent des
des hôpitaux et cetera sont considérés
comme fiables par l'ONU par les ONG qui
travaillent là-bas ils sont très
détaillés
euh on a des des noms des nombre de
famille
euh
après il y a niveau de détail ils sont
utilisés dans les rapports
gouvernementals ils sont pas énormément
contestés par les Isra
je sais que c'est président Biden qui a
fait un commentaire là-dessus mais
c'était très intéressant que juste la
semaine il y a de TR jours un membre de
l'équipe Biden a dit en fait
que il était on a cité sur le fil la FP
que le chiffre est probablement beaucoup
trop bas en fait qu'il y a des gens sous
les bâtiments et
cetera on a écrit des explications sur
comment on utilise ces chiffres je pense
les société de press a fait la même
chose
h et je pense même les gens de l'ONU a
parlé depuis encore une fois sur la la
la fiabilité de ces chiffres bien sûr
parfois c'est ça ça ça va être dans une
situation comme on vit maintenant
parfois des estimations
euh mais ils sont largement considérés
euh comme fiables et est-ce qu'on a la
capacité de fa checker sur le terrain
toutes les c'est détat et cetera non là
où on a des problèmes et c'était écrit
dans notre copie dans les chiffres ils
disent jamais bien sûr qu'ils sont des
combattants
euh ils communiquent beaucoup sur la
quantité
d'enfants c'est pas surprenant étant
donné le mix de la population il y a
énormément de jeunes qui
visent à
Gaza on peut pas être sûr de la quantité
mais tout ce que je peux dire dire c'est
nos journalistes eux-mêmes dans les
hôpitaux dans les morgues dans la rue
ont vu certainement des centaines et des
centaines d'enfants blessés et morts je
peux pas aller plus loin que que que ça
à mais comme j'ai dit c'est c'est c'est
ces chiffres sont sont utilisés par par
beaucoup beaucoup de médias organisation
euh les ONG et et et l'ONU
h et c'est à cause de ça je pense que on
revient sur cet incident à
l'hôpital que beaucoup de médias a
repris cette
info il y avait encore une fois
différentes sources pour cette info sur
la frappe de l'hôpital il y avait un
communiqué qui vient de la partie
militaire de Hamas qu'on a pas touché
qui a parlé de de 500 morts il a une
communiqué qui vient de système
hospitalier qui qui a parlé de je pense
quelques centaines morts qu'on a repris
pr sorcé c'était c'était comme on fait
assz souvent avec une allégation c'était
clairement sorcé à l'administration
médicale sous contrôle de
Hamas
alors est-ce qu'on aura le luxe de ne
pas traiter cette info non parce que ça
partte c'est c'est c'est c'est sur
toutes les chaînes en boucle arabe c'est
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est notre
boulot d'y aller et de contextualiser et
et de faire notre boulot de de
vérification
contextualisation on aurait dû être plus
prudent dans la manière dont on a on a
écrit La Dépêche on aurait dû être plus
ferme sur le fait que AFP était pas sur
place que AFP était pas en mesure de
confirmer l'allégation de de Hamas parce
que c'était une allégation qui était
très
gros la formulation des mots était pas
parfait on a changé nos consignes après
euh pour juste changer la manière dont
on
formule certaines choses qu' on parle de
de
ramas et après la complexité c'était
euh l'attente pour pour vraiment la
partie israélienne on a eu une réaction
assez rapide des israélien qui dit on
est en train de de regarder mais ça a
pris 3 heur pour avoir le
contreenarratif et 3 He dans le temps
réel et c'est toute la complexité du
travail de la FP c'est le travail de
temps réel 3h dans le temps réel c'est
c'est énorme c'est énorme mais bien sûr
dès qu'on a eu la réaction israélienne
on on a alerté on a on a complètement
changé la manière d'écrire les dépêches
on a on a on a fait
tout mais c'est ce 3 He qui est qui qui
qui est
compliqué et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai discuté avec mes mes mes homologues
RP et et il y a pas une solution très
simple à ça parce que c'est c'est le
contexte dans lequel on travaille le
contexte des réseaux le contexte de de
de de voilà de l'information qu'on qu'on
maîtrise pas c'est pas les agences
maintenant qui maîtrisent la diffusion
de l'info l'info parte immédiatement sur
les réseaux et après on chasse après
pour contextualiser mais comme j'ai dit
on aurait dû l'écrire dans une manière
plus prudent est-ce que ça aurait changé
la narratif je suis pas convaincu mais
on sera plus
ferme plus content chez nous si on a
écrit différemment si ça passe une
deuxème fois on la traite
différemment sur le mot terroriste
oui c'est possible de trouver sur le fil
AFP sur les images AFP sur les vidéos
AFP toutes les tweetp des millions et
des millions de
documents des exemples où le style est
pas respecté
parfois le style pour le président
français ou le style pour comment
traiter les immigrants ou le style ça
c'est un boulot en permanence à la FP on
a un énorme manuel de l'agencier que
chaque journaliste à la FP est censé à
comprendre lire tout le
temps on a des nouveaux entrants on a
parfois des stagiaires on a parfois des
gens qui sont parux on a des des gens
qui sont moins bons que d'autres
il y a des erreurs le fait qu'on trouve
le mot terroriste s guillemet sur notre
fil c'est c'est c'est pas surprenant
mais je prends vraiment les questions à
l'inverse y a
99,9 % des situations où le mot
teroriste est déployé sur le sur le fil
c'est dans un contexte correct et aussi
il faut dire que le mot est partout
parce que tout le monde l'utilise tout
le monde l'utilise les les gouvernements
autoritaires voilà les les euh voilà ça
ça ça c'est c'est c'est partout sur
notre
vie
parceor non mais c'est mais c'est c'est
juste pour dire que le le le mot est est
vraiment le mot est vraiment partout et
c'est c'est ça partie de raison on est
obligé d'arriver avec un style parce que
nonement après les événements de 11
septembre c'était dans la la la bouche
de vraiment tout le monde et c'était
extrêmement difficile de de de de faire
une politique de en fait de décider qui
qui est terroriste et pu qui est pas
terroriste
les opposants de de de Monsieur Bachar
al-Assad les opposants de Monsieur
Bachar alAssad c'est des gens proches
d'alqaïda monsieur Bachar alAssad
utilise des armes chimiques contre sa
propre population mais qui qui est le
terroriste c'est extrêmement difficile
d'arriver à choisir qui on n était pas
on éétait pas en Syrie on était on était
au lendemain d'une opération qui était
épouvantable j'espère que vous avez vu
les images qui ont été projeté soit hier
à l'Assemblée nationale où il y a
quelques jours dans dans d'autres lieux
où le caractère
terroriste la caractérisation d'une
attaque terroriste avec ces choses
abominables ne font pas de dupe c'est
vraiment c'est le sens commun qui permet
de le qualifier aussi et c'est le enfin
la France le festival était un Bataclan
en grand un batalan deslobbe un Bataclan
à ciel ouvert non on couvre des choses
abominables partout dans le monde chaque
semaine c'est c'est ça notre difficulté
juste quand on a eu cette discussion
juste avant le le le Bataclan en fait
parce que eu la semaine avant ou
quelques semaines avant il y avait 200
enfants tués dans dans une école dans le
nord de Pakistan
euh on a pas utilisé le mot dans ces
circonstances là on a pas utiliser le
mot euh dans dans cont Bataclan on n pas
utilisé les mot quand il y a 1500
personnes tuées dans le nord de
Mozambique il inclut 400 qui sont
décapités c'est c'est c'est des choses
qu'on couvre partout dans le monde tout
le temps qui est très très très
difficile bah juste pour revenir sur la
politique comme j'ai dit c'était en Phe
qu'on a eu les attendats de Paris et
Charlie Hebdo on n pas eu le polémique
publique qu'on a maintenant c'est
quelque chose qui est respecté par
toutes les gros médias global du
monde et c'est pas pour suivre les
autres médias qu'on le fait mais c'est
c'est c'est c'est pour les Bones
raisons et une chose que je dirais c'est
aussi pour
protéger nos équipes sur le terrain le
moment on commence à décrire les taliban
par exemple en Afghanistan comme des
terroristes on met une cibbe sur le dos
de toutes nos journes là-bas on ferme le
bureau il y a beaucoup d'endroits où on
peut dire la même chosees et ça on est
assz unique les grosses agences d'avoir
beaucoup de journalistes dans des
situations de précarité partout dans le
monde on faisait un boulot très
difficile dans dans un contexte très
difficile on a perdu nous-même des
journalistes qui é tué par l'ét
islamique par les taliban en Afghanistan
et en Syrie
et on gère très bien les les les avec
difficultés mais on sait très bien les
difficultés qui qui en face de de nos
journalistes et ça ça joue aussi dans
dans nos
décisions si je comment on
décide d'avoir cette politique on a des
journalistes qui gère les les standards
leséthiqu les questions déontologiques
il a un réseau de ces journalistes dans
tous les gros médias du monde qui qui en
parlent beaucoup
euh et c'est une discussion qui que
qu'on a entre entre nous à l'agence avec
toutes les équipes chef et il y a pas
énormément de B en terme à l'agence sur
ces questions même si chaque fois qu'on
a une histoire proche de nous on
comprend parfaitement euh l'émotion
c'est voilà euh c'est exactement la même
chose pour nous qu'on a perdu nos
propres journalistes dans des attentats
c'est c'est très difficile
euh sur la question de les les les
sources euh sur le terrain si on parle
de ce que se passe à Gaza euh on en nos
propres journalistes qui sont basés
là-bas qui ont le réseau de contact qui
connaî un peu le
terrain mais la
difficulté ça c'est aussi un élément de
contexte très important pour pour
l'incident à
l'hôpital c'était pas possible d'y aller
immédiatement c'était extrêmement
dangereux c'était toute la zone où
l'armée israélienne a dit c'est exclu
d'être là si vous êtes là vous êtes une
cible ça veut dire que c'était pas
possible juste d'y aller immédiatement
regarder ce que se passe on est allé le
jour après et même là c'était dangereux
il y avait déjà des des frappes autour
de nos équipes moi j'étais pas à l'aise
avec le fait qu'on est y allit mais ils
sont très courageux ils sont allés
là-bas vraiment pour pour filmer pour
interviever pour essayer de comprendre
et on a travaillé sur une grosse enquête
sur sur sur ces questions là pour
essayer de comprendre avec vraiment des
des témoignages des des l'équipe qui
travaille sur les réseaux on on a fait
une grosse enquête pour pour pour
comprendre ce que s'est passé mais mais
mais il faut comprendre que c'est
extrêmement difficile de de faire les
chose qu'on veut faire le plus c'est de
témoigner nous-même sur des choses qui
se passe parce que il y a toujours cette
menace notamment dans dans le nord de
Gaza euh à Gaza City après tous nos
journ sur le terrain travaill avec les
même codes déontologique que que que
tous les autres journalistes à la FP
sont sont tous formés avec les mêmes
règles on fait des formations régulières
souvent les chefs de poste de Jérusalem
quand temps normal moi je suis moimême
allé à Gaza dans le passé pour visiter
notre équipe encore une fois pour
diffuser la culture de
l'agence et encore une fois toute
l'information passe via nos nos
journalistes à Jérusalem c'est c'est pas
il y a tout un système d'édition qui
passe ver jérus et puis uncousi pour
veiller sur sur sur la qualité
de de ce que ils sont en train de faire
c'est une équipe qui est avec nous
depuis longtemps beaucoup d'ux ont gagné
des
prix autour du monde ils sont bien
connus et
oui c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille en terme
de la sécurité oui on a une grosse
frustration en ce
moment ça honnête qu'on peut pas faire
grandchose pour eux normalement la
sécurité des des journalistes à la FP
c'est quelque chose qu'on qu'on qu'on
suit en temps réel des formations des
des voilà des des analyses de risque sur
chaque mission et cetera et cetera mais
là pour notre équipe à Gaza la guerre
est chez eux et ils sont enfermés dans à
gazer ça veut dire ils ont pas l'option
de sortir et nous nous n'avons pas
l'option de de deentrer à gazer qui est
un peu différent des des autres conflits
qu'on a eu à Gaza et ça ve dire dans le
contexte actuel il y il y a très peu de
choses qu'on peut faire pour eux et ça
ça ça fait mal au cœur on reçoit des des
messages de assez désespéré comme j'ai
dit ils ont perdu des membres de la
famille beaucoup d'amis beaucoup de
collègues et ce et c'est c'est c'est
c'est pas facile pour
eux en tant que je pense je vi la
question sur
l'Arménie je prendre l'exemple par
exemple la question de génocide
pourquoi on utilise pas le mot génocide
dans le contexte d'Arménie mais on
utilise pas bien sûr pour pooa pour
Rwanda et même sur et c'est parce que
c'est reconnu par l'ONU et même s'il y a
des des des pays qui qui qui reconnaîent
qu'il y avait une génocide en
Arménie c'est pas quelque chose qui est
reconnu par l' on est obligé de trouver
des sources qui qui fait l' et c'est
même chose en fait sur sur sur sur pour
le terrorisme il faut le dire même si
les États-Unis et et l'Europe utilise le
mot terroriste pour certains de ces
groupes là c'est ça fait pas unanime tu
vois et ça ça ça qui complique les
choses il y a toujours un process de
dialogue pendant toute cette phase de de
la guerre nagor- karabak Arménie on a on
a reçu l'ambassadrice arménienne
plusieurs fois discuté parfois on a
juste des phrases tu vois comment
comment faire des choses on est on est
toujours à l'écoute
des différentes communautés et
certainement on a changé certain cons
dans la manière dont on parle des
séparatistes en Arménie pour pour dire
que c'est que des gens qui les
combattants effectivement pour être sûr
que c'est pas le reste de la population
on parle pas de toute la population
comme des séparatistes mais mais juste
les com ça ve dire on est toujours en
train d'affiner changer adapter et
cetera parce qu'on sait dans le contexte
actuel les mots sont sont extrêmement
sensibles
honnêtement en tête sur la question de
d'un autre exemple de mot j'en suis sûr
il y en a
euh mais j'ai j'ai pas un autre mot en
tête mais pardon je je j'en suis sûr
qu'il y en
a mais mais j'ai pas réponse simple à
ces questionsl
euh et et en qu'oit sur comment on
utilise le mot sur la question Thor si
si quelqu'un jugé par un tribunal
français je reviens à la question que
avant c'est c'est pas juste parce que
une instance dans un pays a décidé qu'
quelqu'un terroriste qu'on qu'on va
changer notre notre politique sur
comment on décrit les les les les
attaqueurs hamass on essaie d'utiliser
des des mots différentes ça ça dépend du
contexte c'est
pas c'est c'est pas il y a des contextes
où c'est intéressant de parler de Hamas
en tant que islamiste notamment dans un
contexte politique ça dépend de de de
quel quel quel est quel contexte euh il
y a pas une règle ferme de de de de de
dire une chose et pas d'autre mais de
trouver des moyens et encore une fois ce
qu'on demande dans nos équipes c'est
vraiment de témoigner en fait quand on
parle là de de par exemple le
terrorisme en fait le défi c'est de de
lire notre copie lire notre copie tout
ce qu'on a décrit dans le sud d'Israël
dans les kibuts dans partout mais c'est
c'est des choses atroces qui qui sont
décrits avec des mots qui qui qui
rendent absolument clair que c'est
atroce et que c'est c'est c'est
dégueulasse c'est c'est c'est le mot
terroriste en fait apporte absolument
rien à nos descriptions c'est ce qu'on
privilége toujours de raconter ce qu'on
voit et je pense si les gens prend un
peu de temps de lire toutes les
reportages qu'on a fait sur ces C cet
attentat on continue de faire les
reportages avec les rescapés de de Rave
partti avec les lescapé des avec les les
familles des otages avec voilà ce qui
se'est passé à Sidro dans dans le sud je
pense que tout ça est
clair je reviens sur la question des
projections l'image les
images juste en terme de contexte avant
qu'on parle d'image parce que c'était
après je pense 2 semaines on a eu cet
événement juste pour dire que
l'après-midi de le 7 octobre il y avait
des photographes et les vid de FP à
Sidro dans le Sud qui a filmé eux-mêm
des imag image atroce qu'on a envoyé à
toutes les 4000 clients autour du monde
notment des gens qui étaient abattus là
en attendant pour un bus dans le voiture
c'est très difficile à regarder ces
images ça veut dire que voilà l'idée
qu'on a un peu fait l'impasse sur les
images difficiles non dès le premier
jour on a fait des images très
difficiles nous-mêmes et aussi nos
équipes étaient en train de interacter
avec des images atroces filmées par has
qui étit mis sur les réseaux à on a
aussi sorcé des images qui sont venu des
des autorités israéliennes notamment les
les gens qui sont sur le terrain pour
pour pour gérer les corps et cetera on a
passé beaucoup d'images photos et vidéos
à nos clients des images difficiles qui
vient parfois des des GoPro caméras de
Hamas et cetera ça vaut dire même avant
cette projection on a fourni des choses
atroce à nos clients et n journ é en
train d'interacter avec ces images
si je viens à à ce ce cet incident ça ça
arrive ça arrive avec la fatigue je
pense que je peux dire que les
projections été plutôt organisées par
les 2000 journalistes qui sont entrés en
Israël après les attentats faut dire
notre équipe a pas pris de jour de repos
au rien pour 2 semaines qui bossse des
des jours de 18 20h par jour oui dans
dans dans ces circonstances parfois on
fait un mauvais jugement on dit tiens ok
on prendre des des éléments ça on
utilise dans un papier de main on
parfois on mesure pas le fait que le nos
collègues vont vont vont vont écrire
quelque chose vont les traiter
différemment mais en fait comment on a
réagi après on a réagi après en deux
trois fois on a écrit sur ces images
même ce matin parce que je pense qu'il y
a une projection avec des députés
aujourd'hui on a refait l'histoire ce
matin on il y a 600 mots sur notre fille
aujourd'hui qui est juste une
description de ce que s'est passé dans
dans ce film je par on peut pas dire
qu'on a a fait l'impasse sur ces images
le fait que on fait des erreurs humaines
erreurs de jugement dans la fatigue et
c'est c'est juste normal ça ça ça arrive
c'est humain pour des gens qui bossent
vraiment
comme comme j'ai dit sans cesse pour 2
semaines 20 par
jour après le Dagestan Dagestan c'est un
exemple très intéressant je pense notre
défi comme j'ai dit c'est de parler de
on travaille dans le temps réel
qui est pas tout est pas toujours clair
dans le temps réel on sait pas ce que se
passe dans le temps réel le jour après
sur les plate télé c'est très très clair
tout est très clair on on on a 18h 15h
de d'information on peut rassembler
quelque chose 15h après qui est très
clair mais dans le temps réel les
premières sources qu'on a eu sur les
choses qui se passent en dagistan comme
on nait pas un correspondant à
l'aéroport à l'époque c'était les médias
russes et les images non vérifié sur les
résseau réseaux
sociaux pardon sur sur tellgram ouais
réseaux sociaux russes ça veut dire que
il faut traiter avec le maximum de
prudence c'est des choses qu'on va pas
vérifier
nous-même mais si on prend la différence
entre ce qu'on a écrit au début qui est
extrêmement prudent qu'est-ce que se
passe on décrit ce que se passe sans
sans sans tout le contexte sans savoir
et ce qu'on a écrit 8h plus tard il y a
pas photo parce qu' après y a la Maison
Blanche qui a parlé de prgurom ah il y a
la réaction de le Premier ministre
israélienne Benjamin nanahou euh on
était capable de de de le faire d'une
manière complètement différent et en
plus qu'est-ce qu'on a fait le jour
après et je pense qu'il y a pas autres
médias qui qui ont fait ce boulot on a
fait un reportage sur la communauté juif
en Russie les les les craintes et les
les les les les le le le situation là et
aussi ici en France en même temps et je
pense il y a pas un autre média qui a
fait ça et ça veut dire les critiques
sur ces couverturees je les comprends
pas du tout c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est malhonnête c'est des gens qui
prendnent un capture d'écran de quelque
chose qui qui se passe en temps réel et
le jour après il dit ah oui tiens vous
avez pas décrit ça comme comme il faut
mais il faut regarder la totalité de la
couverture ça c'est notre boulot
leseffet de vraiment vérifier tout avant
de faire voilà des conclusions et c'est
ce qu'on a fait en fait notre boulot
très bien dans dans cette
histoire je vais prendre comme ça tu
peux boire un peu une une des questions
que vous avez posé votre dernière
question monsieur le Président sur
l'identité française de
l'AFP
on je pense que on a pris cette décision
je n'y étais pas à l'époque mais F il
était à l'agence elle a été prise en
toute autonomie on s'est pas
concerté euh associété de presse et
reter aurait pris une autre mesure je
suis pas sûr qu'on se serait aligné sur
eux
euh encore une fois je pense que si tout
le monde en est arrivé à cette
conclusion c'est parce que on fait le
même métier mais je me suis déjà
expliqué là-dessus on va pas répéter en
revanche l'identité française elle je
dirais même plutôt plus largement
l'identité européenne parce qu'on est
effectivement la seule européenne des
trois mondiales elle est très forte et
c'est on n'est pas la voie de la France
mais on est un regard européen sur
l'actus et je joue un peu sur les mots
et ça c'est une ça se voit tous les
jours dans les reportages qu'on fait
c'est-à-dire d'abord sur la présence
terrain nos concurrents vont aller se
concentrer sur les régions qui
intéressent leurs
clients nous on a une présence vraiment
mondiale et dans le choix des sujets
qu'on prend je pense qu'on va les
traiter
différemment de la manière dont ils sont
traités par par nos concurrents et donc
on est assez fier de ce de cette
identité européenne on la refoule
absolument pas et on ne cherche à aucun
moment de
s'aligner sur nos
conurs je crois que c'est important de
le le le
redire il une dernière question de de
Pierre-Antoine levvich oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le le
Président Monsieur directeur
d'information permettez-moi de vous dire
que j'étais assez mal à l'aise en
écoutant les explications je ne sais pas
si je suis le seul euh en vous entendant
essayz de justifier le fait que vous
n'appeliez pas euh ne qualifiez pas
parce que c'est pas dans votre règle de
qualifier le le mot de terroriste or
vous l'avez fait avec plusieurs
plusieurs fois dans le passé comme l'a
indiqué Bruno rotayo vous l'avez fait
également sur Al-Qaïda peut-être que si
euh il avait été indiqué que le ramas
Ctait une organisation terroriste c'est
aussi un moyen de différencier le peuple
palestinien du Hamas ce qui est pas le
cas normalement et aujourd'hui qui qui
en pay qui en paye des conséquences je
je trouve très surprenant que que cette
charte s'applique encore parce que il y
a pas de difficulté à qualifier un acte
de terroriste quand il est un acte de
terroriste comment qualifieriez-vous si
un journaliste de la FP était assassiné
dans le cadre d'un attentat terroriste
qu'est-ce que vous diriez est-ce que
c'est un attentat terr on l' pas
qualifié de terroriste dans les les cas
qu' cité fil on n'a pas utilisé ce mot
ilble qu' faut on a parlé d'un attentat
djihadiste en l'occurrence cétait
beaucoup plus précis oui mais c'est un
quand même terroriste il me semble le
c'est c'est un meurtre c'est un massacre
c'est un une attaque à l'arme blanche
c'est une décapitation oui il y a plein
de mots qui peuvent être utilisés qui
sont tout a oui mais pour le grand
public monsieur le Président et ça a
choqué beaucoup de personnes ça a choqué
parce que on est pas là pour faire le le
procè la FP on est là pour essayer de
comprendre ça a choqué beaucoup de
personnes que lafp ne qualifie pas cet
acte de terroriste tout simplement parce
que c'est un acte de terrorisme comme
c'était un acte de terrorisme ban je
voudrais vous poser une question à côté
de ça sur les propos dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure sur lesfin les
accusations d'antisémitisme d'un député
récemment vous avez indiqué que si ne
retirez pas ces propos vous porteriez
plainte où est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer où on en est aujourd'hui sur
cette affaire ben il ne les a pas retiré
donc nous allons porter
plainte par
ailleurs je sais
pas moi je suis un peu décontenané parce
qu'on passe des heures à s'expliquer sur
ce sujet encore une fois faut ramener le
sujet à des à des vraies proportions on
n'hésite pas à dire les atrocités on l'a
dit avec des mots qui sont qu'on juge
précis d'accord on n'empêche aucun média
d'utiliser le mot terroriste les médias
sont nos clients encore une fois on
s'adresse pas au grand public on
s'adresse aux médias les médias ils
veulent des choses extrêmement précis
précises ils veulent savoir qui parle
sur le la qualification du Hamas comme
organisation terroriste comme l'a dit
Phil le sud global on va le dire comme
ça ne ne reconnaît pas le Hamas comme
organisation terroriste ça compte ça
compte donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on dit
le Hamas qui est reconnu comme
organisation terroriste par l'Union
européenne les États-Unis et Israël et
cetera et cetera et qui par ailleurs ne
reconnaît pas le droit d'Israël à
exister bon s où est le problème les
médias sont assez grands pour faire ce
qu'ils veulent derrière donc vous aurez
le monde qui ira dire que c'est un
groupe terroriste peut-être tel autre
médiia dans une autre région ne le
qualifiera pas de tel et choisira ses
mots mais les les médias sont assez
grands pour le faire et les médias je je
n'ai pas connaissance peut-être qu'en
faisant cette déclaration je vais avoir
je vais appeler à des à des réactions
mais les médias ne ne ne nous ont fait
aucun pour eux c'est c'est ce n'est pas
un sujet donc on on est on monte en
épingle un sujet depuis des semaines
c'est quand même dingue c'est dingue
faut
arrêter à aucun moment on est ni les
atrocités du 7 octobre on vous on vous
dit que même lors des attentats de
Charlie sur notre sol F était récteur en
chef la c'était une directrice de
l'information française qui était à
l'époque le débat était tranché en ce
sens il y a pas eu de polémique il y a
pas eu de polémique donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y en aurait une
aujourd'hui je je peut-être je veux
juste ajouter que enc fois il y a a il y
a il y a aucune différence il y a pas
dans la manière dont on on traite à
masque la manière dont TR alqïa j'ai pas
même essayé de regarder sur 20 ans si
quelqu'un a utilisé le mot terroriste
sur les millions de documents qu'on a
passé sur Hamas peut-être ça existe
parce que encore une fois quand on passe
autant de contenu avec des gens qui
travaillent partout dans le
monde c'est ça ça ça va arriver mais la
politique est absolument la même pour
pour pour pour
tous
bien messieur merci de de de ce réponse
tant que vous nous avez donner pour
essayer d'apporter des éclaircissements
je crois que ce ce temps d'échange était
nécessaire merci
beaucoupcip